even the most ardent of horror
enthusiasts sometimes have to draw the
line in an age in which advancing
effects technology has made it possible
to depict incredibly realistic gross
outs there's still a limit to the amount
of guts and gore audiences will watch
before they throw in the popcorn and
give up here are some horror movies that
audiences walked out of the Devil's
Rejects Rob Zombie's sophomore fright
feature a sequel to 2003 s the house of
a thousand corpses relied on the same
dark imagery and violence that made its
predecessor so utterly disturbing by
turning the knob down just to touch on
the slash and shock factor in favor of
some more emotionally upsetting moments
with the Devil's Rejects zombie earned
praise from a greater number of critics
but you still had some moviegoers
hitting the door long before the credits
roll I'm gonna have to be taking your
car today
jabs top secret clown business and
supersedes any plans that you might have
for this year ryuko Evil Dead the 1981
version of the Evil Dead was troubling
enough but the 2013 remake of the creepy
cult favorite showed off some true
next-level savagery including a moment
of possessed self-mutilation of a girl's
face and a lot of vomit spewing among
other debauchery early viewers of the
year's South by Southwest festival in
Austin Texas got an unexpected live
soundtrack edition the sounds of many
feet carrying their owners away from the
ultra graphic brutality according to
Bruce Campbell who starred in the
original series and served as producer
of the remake all the walkouts were
considered a win for the team he told
Hollywood calm that's the sign of a good
horror movie
groovy the witch critics might have been
crazy about this slow building period
pick about 17th century family tormented
by evil but some audiences didn't quite
appreciate the drawn-out nature of the
narrative which depended less on jump
scares than creepy atmosphere and a more
traditional and for some flat-out dull
slow building story instead of being
sent running by the gore this time it
was the bore factor that drove audiences
to the exits so what you're telling me
is to be bored and then bored and
finally bored again but this time for
the rest of my life the witches greatest
magic trick the incredible disappearing
audience raw some candid film goers got
much more than their eyes or stomachs
could handle in 2016 when Julia Duke
renews raw presented them with the story
of a young vegetarian woman who was
hazed into eating raw meat during school
an act of bullying that awaken the
dormant flesh fetish that was sickening
enough to send audiences rushing for the
exit signs whether raw fits within the
usual buffet of slashers or not it
certainly left a taste in everyone's
mouth afterward the Texas Chainsaw
Massacre when the world first met
Leatherface and tobe Hooper is 1974
slaughter fast the brazen butchery was
too gruesome for some audience members
to take the film in which the power tool
wielding weirdo trapped and decimated an
entire group of young friends in ghastly
ways was even banned in several
countries and was originally rated X for
its grisly violence one of the scenes
that got to audiences most frequently
was the moment when a girl named Pam was
strung up on a meat hook and made to
watch as her friend was sliced and diced
by Leatherface his trusty title weapon
he'll never look at me the same way
again
[Music]
audition when this 1999 Japanese torture
thriller debuted at the Rotterdam Film
Festival it won director takashina me
case some of the festival's most
prestigious prizes and impressed and
inspired fellow horror otters like Eli
Roth John Landis and Rob Zombie the
movie's hyper realistic violence was too
difficult to endure for some audience
members though and one woman was even
quoted to scream of the director
your evil during the screening it wasn't
just the eye gouging in piano wire foot
amputations that made the pic such a
squirmy event it was also the fact that
the tone took such a drastic turn for
the worse in its third
after the main character discovered that
the woman he auditioned hence the title
to be his new wife had a twisted history
of inflicting pain on people up to and
including making a prisoner eat her own
barf
thanks Japan no God no God please no no
the human centipede
there was enough of an audience interest
in the sick experimentation on display
and Tom six is the human centipede
to justify two sequels an episode of
South Park at a key & peele sketch in
which former members of a human
centipede all run into each other at a
restaurant call me that but some have
braved the theatres to witness what
happens when a surgeon stitches together
three living humans digestive systems
together couldn't bear to stick around
and see what came out at the end the so
called first sequence was largely
inspired by the notorious diabolical
work of Josef Mengele at the Auschwitz
concentration camp during World War two
but the director also said he came up
with his sinister plot after watching
the news friends and it was a really
nasty looking a child molester on and
and suddenly I made this joke I said
they should Stitch his mouth to the S of
a very fat truck driver as a punishment
and everybody says ah that's just a
horrible idea
no offense Tom but next time listen to
your friends thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos at the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know which horror movie made you want to
walk out